just start for all you entrepreneurs
we're waiting for the perfect time to
start a business or the perfect time to
launch that next product or service idea
that you have I'm going to share a clip
that was supposed to be private but I
asked her permission one of my
mastermind group members who runs a
youtube channel called Rishi Cup TV that
I hope will inspire you ok for sharing
i'm going to show you these two pictures
you
so the reason I wanted to show you guys
his picture pictures is just to be a
reminder that we all have to start
somewhere with whatever we have and I
know for me I could have really really
been super ashamed of the things that I
didn't have when I first started Russia
Cup TV but if I had done that I would
not have made any progress and taken any
action and so you know we're all at
different places and so just kind of
wanted to encourage you guys and that
who cares what you don't have just go
for it and yeah so hopefully that helps
this is an important message and I'm
really proud of Rishi you know she's a
super perfectionist and I feel like a
lot of entrepreneurs are perfectionist
and until until the perfect time comes
along or until everything is lined up
exactly as we want it we're not going to
launch and in reality that is rarely how
companies and projects get started right
if you look at any company look at their
roots it wasn't from getting millions of
dollars in venture capital and starting
right they started on no budget they
started with a lot of hustle and driving
energy and as money came in they
funneled the back into their company and
they built it up I look at the history
of my youtube channel when I started it
it was just me right I didn't know
anything about camera or Lighting's or
microphones I had none of that it was me
and my camera and I put it on a
bookshelf and I just had it set to
record me and now I've been able to
build it to have people who helped me
Jason's here filming Christina's editing
Ivan's doing research you know I've got
a team of people now who helped me out
but a lot of people wait until they get
those people in line before they'll even
start and those people never come and so
you just sit on those ideas never
actually taking action so understand
that when you start it's going to suck
your quality will suck your your
delivery will suck you won't know
exactly what kind of product or service
to make your product and service will
change many
x over the history of your company
that's okay start the right time to
start is right now go do it believe I
love to know from you guys in the
comments how you started if it was
ghetto if it was no budget I'm really
curious if we could share your story to
help inspire others leave it in the
comments below and also check out Rishi
cap TV you know she had the courage to
say yes to let me put this video public
on my channel that's a vulnerable moment
so go check out her channel subscribe to
her leave a comment in the pillow to
support her thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon